votre mot préféré c'est aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui avec une apostrophe au
milieu le mot vous détestez un mauvais
sentiment décrit par un mauvais mot
concupiscence le son le bruit que vous
aimez c'est le son très discret des
pages que je tourne en lisant un livre
ou le sont aussi discrets du stylo sur
la feuille laplante l'arbre où l'animal
dans lequel vous aimeriez être réincarné
j'aimerais bien être réincarné dans un
cep de la romanée-conti votre juron gros
mots ou blasphème favori oh [ __ ] au
[ __ ] au [ __ ] toujours trois fois
homme ou femme
pour illustrer un nouveau billet de
banque
michel bouquet dans l'avare de molière
enfin si dieu existe
qu'aimeriez vous après votre mort
l'entendre vous dire
alors mr byron adu you do pas terrible
je i'm sorry my god bataille don't speak
english
mais c'est vrai qu'on ne parlait pas
anglais il parle français évidemment
audio c1 c'est vrai que vous parlez pas
anglais et bien vous avez toute
l'éternité devant vous pour apprendre
l'anglais et je vais vous donner un très
bon professeur s'il vous plaît allez me
chercher sur william shakespeare of
course
[Musique]